[Applause]
yeah it's local news where each guest
has to share a story from wherever
they're from I'm your host Brett van
Jansen Chet's taller chubbier cousin
Morgan you go first well we have a young
24 year old man in Nashville who
unfortunately rang up an 8 000 tab at a
sports bar and then he actually from
when he started till the because I guess
they authorized the charge at the
beginning by the end of the night he
turned off his credit card said he
didn't agree with the charges and he
actually got arrested because we don't
put up with that in Tennessee for real
yeah yeah he did and by the way that's a
big tip that the that the waiters didn't
get no no question but knowing Nashville
did he get arrested for skipping the tab
or did he actually drive home after
drinking eight thousand dollars worth of
money I hope not that I hope not but
listen he yeah he said that he didn't
agree with the charges and so he stopped
he froze he called the credit card
company and froze his credit card and
sat there all night drinking don't do
that everybody comes to Nashville for
your Bachelor parties have fun pay your
bar tab to tip your waitress thank you
yes thank you well said
Catherine Tim
oh boy I'm so excited are you though
there's a boss babe Alert in Wisconsin
okay usually when you think here about
boss babes in the media they're like
selling workout shakes and stuff this
lady Brooke Fleetwood has a real estate
portfolio and she painted another one of
her houses pink to capitalize off of the
Barbie movie she said Barbie was
inspiration so I need to hurry up and
paint this pink very quickly to keep up
with the Barbie movie to keep up with
the demand I just love the idea of her
screaming at people to paint it faster
so that she could make money because
then they asked her if she seen the
movie and she said I'm waiting for all
the hype to die down so I can in peace
[Laughter]
I love her I think she's great I don't
know her but I don't need to know her to
know that I love her I like her vibe
yeah and I can't make fun of Barbie
because in this jacket I look like Ken's
older brother can't you know
you know
looking at that house though I'm pretty
sure there is no kin
no a lot of pink oh that's funny it
doesn't come with a Corvette it comes
with a Subaru yeah is that what you're
telling me
Harvey's dream Subaru ah Jamie we head
your way
so the article I have and this actually
kind of sad so I live in Fairbanks
Alaska you may know that so this article
is that this the title is the most
depressed depressing town I've ever
visited one Taurus says about Fairbanks
Alaska I was first surprised that it was
only one tourist
foreign
but this guy said he said it was it was
so mean he said it was like dark
depressing there was no future and
people got mad and they were like next
time you go why don't you visit more
things than just Jamie and his ex-wife's
house
I love it I do love it there because my
kids live there so that's where I hang
out with my kids but for real if you go
like I would I would recommend like do a
cruise or something don't get trapped
there through a marriage and have to
um
it's just so much cheaper the cruise is
like so much cheaper and there's
um
laughs
but it can get depressing dude like
there's like sometimes during the winter
there's only one hour of daylight one
can you imagine and so I like it though
because I feel like really productive
when there's only one art you know I'd
be like man I do stuff all day today you
know and like
and of course the darkness gets to you
know I call my friends and go man the
dark is like it gets it gets depressing
you know I kind of you know I want to
feel like killing myself but um it's so
dark I can't even find a rope so
I should I should have quit one ago
and that's why I wrote the review
[Laughter]
but it's signed jk just kidding Tyrus
take it away uh so last night with all
the bumps and bruises and marks in my
head I you notice I'm missing something
I lost 12 pounds uh I defended the NWA
world heavyweight championship against
my lifetime arch nemesis ez3 and uh if I
lost I would retire and I lost and I'm
retired from wrestling
20 years
and it was also Bittersweet there was we
defended it EC3 and I broke in together
in the WWE and it was a it was a great
night it was cool my kids walked the
aisle with me it was a great way to say
goodbye
um and it was a Bittersweet weekend
because retiring is a good thing but
unfortunately I lost a dear friend uh
the right before I actually had a
stand-up show
because I do everything in groups
Thursday at a stand-up show 30 minutes
from going out and uh Windham rotunda a
lot of people would know him as Bray
Wyatt uh died at his home and it was a
very very somber said weekend in the
irony of life I put I said sometimes the
worst thing about entertainment
sometimes is real life shows up and uh
real life showed up 10 minutes before I
went outstage and had to make people
laugh but we do what we have to do we
got it done uh to his family my
condolences but I'm glad I left it all
out there in the ring and I will miss
him
Maybe
and you just really quick you got to
look at the flip side of this okay you
got paid for years to beat people up as
opposed to guys like me and Jamie who
pay to get beat up you know what I mean
so I think it was amazing give it up for
Tyrus
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else